[Music]
I'm it Blizzcon 13 that's right which
celebrates World of Warcraft among
others yeah I'm here late I went to
blitz con 13 which is a celebration of
Wolf Blitzer let me ask you about this
guy is this guy wearing a wolf
or is he in the process of being
swallowed by a wolf and it's taking a
long time the wolf is like I got it I
got it
Justin I got it can and this has
probably happened where players have met
online and then subsequently become
involved have you ever taken advantage
of that my wife would have Jack how did
you meet your wife
plenty World of Warcraft what character
was she when you met she was a troll
named dead rat okay yeah by the way
there's gonna be a great story for your
grandchildren
let me tell you how your grandmother and
I met so you're gonna take me through
the game what's begin absolutely first
of all this guy yes he's standing still
but he seems out of breath I'm guessing
he has one lung who's this guy this is a
dwarf and you know what I prefer a
little person
well okay but he's actually a hunter and
his that's his bear that's it there and
his bear is also breathing heavily and
seems to be in heat who's your sexiest
there's a contingent of people who
really appreciate the female dran i oh
look at those thighs some people like
the horns and then she has a little tail
on the back she's a tail you can turn
her around there so I can check out her
butt yeah this feels really creepy
how do people just click on a girl
character and then slowly turn around
never really quite again I think at some
point people are ready to kind of take
the next step I would not move on from
this step
I'll just stay right here so let's go
ahead and have you pick a race and I'm
gonna go with male okay work great
alright so here you are in the world and
now how do I plant a banner click on
that button right there
Oh what did I just go it's okay you're
inside that guy that's fine I don't want
to be a site of guy am I going to the
edge of something yeah this is a
precipice here that we're not letting
you go up and you might be able to jump
off if you want to and hit spacebar
Oh what I just do that's cool Wow what's
wrong with this looks flooring so you've
died I died I got the genic clip this
guy's armored to the hilt
he's a monster that looks like he's got
9 inch thick skin and he just jumped
into snow and he's dead large clip okay
who's this guy I want to kill him no
he's a friendly I want to kill him can't
really kill friendlies in life you can
business works
so here's a guy right here this blue and
all these are real players who are
actually playing right here hello how
are you that person just walked away
from me and didn't answer my question
this is enraging me hey can I use foul
language
yes hey dick I question good memories
parent he ran away
so Barrett is not dealing with me at all
hey did I asked you a freaking question
he may not actually know that you're
talking to oh ah there he is
he's attention you mad going to open a
can of whoop-ass think I'm joking I'm
going to I'm standing there with a World
of Warcraft team you're a team yes yes
we're to clean your room what character
do you play what race are you i play a
druid you were doing and what are you
I'm focusing mostly on deaf knights and
elemental seven for the suspension okay
I didn't understand a word of that it's
a good idea will you die today or do you
think you will not die we will not die
okay I didn't think I would die and you
know what happened to me I fell into the
snow is falling into the snow what did I
do wrong
before the society take call it doesn't
mention you die usually it's my fault
yeah what's your [ __ ] fool no nine
[Music]
[Applause]
what did you up see Hitler Hitler Hitler
yeah you're giving up are you
[Music]
welcome back to Blizzcon we are here for
the World of Warcraft arena we do have a
special guest with us at today I don't
know Brian karna Brian thank you
Thank You Adam Wow so how much do you
know about World of Warcraft I've played
it for about 16 minutes okay then I was
killed when I fell into a snowbank I
think I'll be the best color commentator
you've ever had
all right and if you're following along
at home on Twitter make sure you use a
hashtag Blizzcon and tweet your
prediction - Tag Team Coco if you're a
fan and if you are watching at home and
following us on Twitter you should
probably get your own apartment
eventually
all right they are entering this large
chamber which seems to have a stone
floor it's fascinating
interesting choice of floor before to
clean stone floor I'm seeing a lot of
flame I'm seeing a lot of green fire I'm
seeing a lot of running around it's all
playing out just as I predicted oh did
you just see what happened did you see
what happened I heard the crowd react I
didn't know what happened but I acted as
if I had I have no idea who won could
you please just tell me quickly
let's go cap one check yes yes I do that
it's go capital course yeah it's
interesting with flash holds I do
believe it was warrior lock shaman as
their their main compensate brought in
yes that's true they brought in the
shaman standard move movie didn't
surprise anybody really any shaman was
able to bring various potions and skills
lotions creams switching it over to
prank cat they might get the bubble out
of him goes down to 2k
I'm not sure if he still had this bubble
or not incredible I don't think he did
have his bubble bubble is on the global
cooldown which means you can cast a
spell every everyone you go SEC explain
that to me
I would once again love to know who won
the game snow still falling snow
expected through the weekend sure you
get those changes huge damage on the top
it's not looking good he's probably
gonna go down to dock damage here oh
there you go there you have it there you
have it
Wow still cap one place you don't have
to dumb it down from me out of the
greatest game in the world
gentlemen thank you so much thank you
thank the crowd for being here and what
can I say it's all about this game it's
the name we will try world of warcraft
[Applause]